I would like to move on to,
if you have time,
I would like to move on to
question about religion because I'm really interested in,
uh,
in myths and religion.
And
one thing that's,
I mean,
if,
if you call something a myth then it's probably not,
well,
it's not a not alive anymore perhaps.
I mean,
if you're actually calling it the myth,
if you really believe in it,
you're not believing that it is a myth.
And so where we are now,
we've,
we've been studying the,
uh,
the Bible like scientifically and,
and so we'd be construct,
my first subject in university was religious studies and then you deconstruct
the Bible and you learn about [inaudible] when everything was written and
everything.
But what would you do right now?
You sort of,
you making the Bible in your Bible lectures,
you making it accessible for people that of our our age or our,
uh,
yeah.
And uh,
and people who would,
I don't think would match,
you wouldn't have naturally turned to the Bible for counseling.
You,
I think
cured completely.
It's just an indication of how surreal the current circumstances really are.
I've been selling out the theater that I booked in Toronto for these biblical
lectures and it's all full of,
it's almost all young man.
I can not that young,
you know,
they're between say 18 and 30,
something like that.
Although they're,
you know,
there's women in there and there's older people too,
but that's the main audience.
And it's like,
well that's crazy.
Right?
That's impossible that that's happening.
But it's an attempt to revive a Phi the myth.
Yeah.
So what's your,
what's your take take on why?
Why is uh,
I asked,
uh,
we should dork is this,
when I interviewed him,
like there are people there were worried about the postmodern challenge to
everything.
Like,
like deconstructing everything.
And so you look for something from in,
in,
in your,
in your life.
And what I see you doing,
and I would like you to your thoughts on it,
is that you are bringing some,
like a firm you're trying to bring in sort of a firmer foothold.
Yes,
exactly.
That it's like I'm journeying to the bottom of the ocean to rescue the father
from the,
from the fire breathing whale.
Like,
that's exactly it.
It's like the thing is,
is that when everything shakes,
then you look for the foundation.
Right?
Right.
And to me,
the foundation,
the,
the thing the West got right is the divinity of the individual.
Right.
It's true.
And it's the myth idea.
This is partly where I had a discussion with Sam Harris.
You know,
that was quite a difficult discussion,
um,
to discussions.
I wasn't in the best of physical health when I had them,
unfortunately,
but that's life.
But you talk when you talk about myth,
you know,
it sounds like untruth,
but I think about it sort of as Metta truth.
It's truer than true in some sense because it consists of abstractions that have
guided human behavior properly for forever.
In so far as human beings have been successful.
Um,
and even in so far as we define success,
it's embedded within these mythological ideas,
which are ideas that we act out essentially not ideas that we hold or,
or believe or state their ideas that we act out.
And the idea of the divine individual is at the center of our law,
which is why,
for example,
even if you're accused of murder,
even if there's overwhelming evidence against you,
you still have value that the state cannot nearly trample on.
And that's,
well,
first of all,
it's unbelievable.
That's the case because you know,
the typical barbaric society,
let's say,
which is what we're trying to reproduce very rapidly,
is the one that assumes that if you're accused of something,
we might as well just shoot you on the off chance that you're guilty.
That's a way easier to,
to adopt that as a principal.
And it,
and it's certainly satiates the Ma,
the blood lust of the mob much more effectively.
The idea that we could have constructed a worldview that put the pathetic week
malevolent,
insufficient,
vulnerable individual at the center of the value structure is just,
it's an accomplishment who's grandier cannot possibly be overstated.
And we,
we are the beneficiaries of that system.
We live within its protective confo confines and we're doing everything we
possibly can to destroy it as rapidly as possible.
So,
so you,
uh,
which it was a one of my idols growing up and uh,
I read the hero with a thousand faces,
isn't too,
is a power of myth lectures.
Uh,
because uh,
I mean as,
as a lot of young men,
I loved Star Wars and the Lord of the rings and then you sort of,
you read his work and you find out that,
okay,
so your [inaudible] he based his storyline or he changed his storyline,
fit more into the hero where the,
the monomyth and be the hero's journey story.
And he said that you need,
you need sort of a living myth or theology to be,
to have psychological health and spiritual health.
You need to live with enough sort of a living mythology.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Big while the methodology tells you who you really are.
Like you know,
you,
you really are a divine son of God.
I mean people,
people,
people and and you know,
you actually know that because you feel guilty about not living up to your
potential.
Why in the world would you possibly feel that?
But everyone feels that if they have any sense at all,
unless they're narcissistic or psychopathic,
everyone feels that burden of the perfection to which they have to perfection to
which they have not yet aspired Nora attained.
And so,
and that's a testament to the,
to the overwhelming potential that characterizes each individual.
And that's really what I'm trying to point out in the biblical lectures.
There's these continual stories about the nature of humanity and the nature of
proper being in the face of the tragedy and malevolence of life.
And the Bible is Western,
the Western world's attempt to,
to,
to formulate that as a,
as a comprehensible set of stories and also a set of principles for behavior.
It's,
it's the collective struggle of our,
of our imagination stretched across tens of thousands of years,
maybe hundreds of thousands of years,
maybe even more than that.
You know,
cause some of these stories,
the Snore,
the story of confronting the malevolence serpent,
like I believe that in one form or another,
that story is if you also consider it as something that could be acted out that
stories at least 60 million years old.
So because Lynn is veiled,
this anthropologist at Ucla has demonstrated quite nicely that are tree dwelling
relatives coevolved with snakes,
and our continual battle with snakes and predatory reptiles was part of what
gave us our acute vision.
Cool.
Yeah.
You know.